J'ordonne à mon administration de
suspendre le financement de l'Organisation
mondiale de la santé pendant qu'un examen est effectué
pour évaluer le
rôle de l'Organisation mondiale de la santé et la grave
mauvaise gestion et la dissimulation de la propagation
du virus corona, la WHL a échoué dans
ce devoir fondamental et doit être tenue
responsable
bonjour de pasilla para perdre acte et
polyfoam allah sawas et lazatti
dans le traceur de point fédéral quitter les
interprètes CJ attendent devant Allah appelé
Rosa peut-il scellé esthétique
sophistiquée Jenkins oppa première
soie Cardozo Eric Thomas un échantillon gratuit d'une
puce cantonaise Karamu pour les termes de
la  gilets homme skybridge capitale tarif
très public un chantier va incendier
un directeur visuel la communication un
missile explose vecteur monsieur traumatisme qui
cause les Israéliens de façon plus loin signifie
avance notre nez c'est un jaune bienvenue
dans notre programme c'est Karrueche c'est bon d'
être ici merci  vous pour m'avoir
merci comme avant tout bien mr.  scanner
Meucci soir Madame
allez depuis que j'ai coupé le
temps de communication n'est pas blonde elle vient circuler un
manque de duel carnaval frottis virus pour pouvoir
massacrer la station de Fermata à
venir Ripley dans un chien vertical ctrader
Diwali le chef c'est l'oiseau mâle le président
est le chef  voici venir élégie le lien
bien sécurisé la taille distance maximale SEO
social national Maya Vossler Sotelo
kushma a au niveau est quelque chose à la
minute
près Les carnivores Voeckler peuvent faire des ravages
suggèrent que la
marée Abita s'est littéralement approchée de la
seconde pour devenir totalement invisible et les
caméras ne le font plus  dire ternir vérifier le
si leadership une deuxième évaluation non ii
s'est battu contre un fan pour ne pas répéter une
tromperie l'hostile blam saké mec moka
à lazuli retour train de ferran
intensité une conférence pokemon déprimé
virgule y hasta la noche fille mr.
Pascal est un moins traumatisé une dent n'est pas une
révision inévitable hakama voir un
laminage voir donc Twitter
ouais de forma donc par exemple dans une auberge
oblems sollicitude allah gouverneur swahili
président fenêtre
koalas éducation universitaire américaine que j'ai
particulièrement dans une approbation de silicium Zika
absolument idiot pardesi  ne
s'est pas excusé auprès des aéroports les actions sont devenues un
lac un an peut-être un peu plus court ha
voir une autorité laïque civilité pas
constitution ne pas reconsidérer Digimon
mère déclaré marché à lapaki NEPA
explicite Marisa rapport fédéral ou via
Zeta no Tina drame politique VAR el amor
como arezzo Don  Sunnyvale un si
constitutionnel peut mashallah haleter mon si
totalement booze quand cet
équipement de location à effet fédéral ne
protège que le mobilier respiratoire
médical kuruvamma clocher fédéral Mayo
imbécile
City food son corps Lucido son encore
blump sont considérés comme un chef dribble un
dunker Sabhas illa chef le tribal  est C
conférer du prix plus l'
arène de connaissance du lemme d'herbe
elessedil rasa la langue basque tout nouveau
gourou
pour la première nouvelle amour équité plus
Twitter et Hamas autres offres les plus
socialement à venir personnellement savoir pourquoi M. P
- K longue stratégie Satan le Calvin
assume une certaine stratégie l'
effet tribalisme Wallach au retour électoral
a tendance DCD à protéger  il viendra et
repartira à Osaka Zita madame silver Belle de
lavit populaire mais a coulé j'ai dit des millions
de travail appelé l'assurance voyage le
Gangetic électoral le programme qu'il Bal
est des adresses en effervescence juste une excuse peut-être
imaginer habilement proposée Veda
missiny aucun débutant proposé  sont UMP
ne nous cherche pas Yamato Dora chefs
Google dans les chefs paramédic dans le
chef spot virus est juste Trump noix de cajou une
danseuse nuit la cerva bascule motel d'accord
ma terriblement ne peut pas faire de sensation
trompé sur une fidélité nespa considérer
est devenu chef pas oh  s'il vous plaît contra a
subi le capot président calme
abonnez-vous à une éventuelle personne porno
responsable du
catalyseur Ashley c'est ouais le pour le
Patriot
le  plein mur devrait près de Salim n'était pas
beaucoup de visite en haute mer voir et un patron Eve
plus vaguement et le padishah Vedanta
s'il vous plaît comme vous commettez un atout
vous voudriez quelle solution de cactus moi
oui
Emma coucou a attiré la popularité dans la popularité de
la liqueur de citron du zoo de la ville du tabac
cet attribut Casteel le
terrain vacant à la pequeña
- basse machina dans le reste vez les
femmes occupées n'aiment pas un équipement de fitness
hélas Ozma LaVon Isola dr.  Fauci la paz
expedition passive ooh tue le pauvre Ozzy
confortable dr.  Falchi qui n'était pas moi sur
Twitter est un médecin régulier immédiat
Falchi Prensa plus énergique la
critique Emily ce n'est que le président
Trump l'économie réelle les dépôts de tourbe une
économie mûre pourrait régler des mauvaises collections économiques personnelles
[Musique]
pour 50p risotto
avec le signal feta  avec le foie dans les
courses opieop arnaquer sur un Anamika cosmique
pour un graphique de copie
non dire clairement la colonne l'atout juste
liatris l'éléphant joue l'économie de la demande
couper rama dire suce une Volvo près de moi esto
pasa Hellickson vois pas la voix ma Pabu
roucoule oh alors sauve un  pauvre homme un Volvo
Joseph Parker président dollar moderne
agonie direction panda en récession
Nalini doula direction potentiellement bon
garçon capacité dans le futur masculin exclu mas
Knesset austérité Aleve Hema trachée
rencontrer clairsemé Casa de Madrid indépendant un
juste démocratiquement gardé Je garde pour elle Lavetta
Keystone à Scotts  marre du
minimal nazi ouais Bernie Sanders un
Biden prématuré ou Audrey simcha Obama
kiriza appel je ne reçois pas  Rama
naturel Camela exclusif Ashura a rendu
service au démocrate Kerry Sanders
Rhodésie pour déposer un mr universel.
Trump esq cellophane - oh pauvre mr.  Trump
s'est opposé à Shammi dans l'exclusion féminine
Moshe Travelocity octobre Oh maman et
Access Hollywood le gentil a secoué sur un
revers Perkins pasa une agonie mortelle non pas de
bip cul encore des soldats commandant une bombe
cachée parmi les Trump succombent au sexe la
seconde à moi avoir l'actrice de
Cahokia  vivre République dominicaine
sur la partie passée de mr quasi indisponible
.  Jim le pedeu
dit Bernie Sanders avvocato trade Sarah
un vide une température critique dites les
enfants ahoy vous à l'
homme dissolu Elva Kosala de Joe Biden j'ai en fait le
Joe Biden d'accord avec Selma je suis Joe Biden
sur une carte de Rama madame contient tout elle
Donald Trump  le cimetière du parc échantillon
Joe Biden la voix Savita dit électrique
même placage Ducati les moteurs Biden
Républicain DiPietro majesté chef Emmalee
Colavecchia poison Obama ne dors pas
ici Lopakhin de minuit de Susie voir
un président gouverner sa vie
fonctionne voir un système qui fonctionne
donne un  lourd narvi buku Doris pepra Le
président Obama pour fixer le coût certain
de voir qu'il peut faire du mouvement mais le mot rusev
tôt ne devrait pas remplacer le présent
Obama Ted
universitaires Attica me consolation sur le pourboire
exemple c'était la persona Kamla Maria de
oñate mm emoni émerge 3 je suis devenu  le modèle
II pourrait renouveler servir le monde un message
de Canarsie padishah rapporte que le
Potala m'a manqué
Rupa six d'amalgame Ohio Canada la
dorade apparaît kala  kala
loon évite le drôle - la visibilité est
Mark la curiosité dit extrêmement mal
nourri être même pas autorisé à bouger un
plus tard ouais sancorp est gravement malade ouais
à personne foie cochléaire Jeanne tress
table plus tard Kamala une progression est
Olivia J jouer sur cette autorité
la présence oppressante de Rama d'Emma impertinente parmi les
capacités mousse de foie traiter la
réplicabilité
résultat de la catalyse approbation moi pour voir les
gens Adler directeur tu sais que tu es boo se
connecter de présenter un poste d'excuse d'amour
tue sur les pays nourris sur un arbre mr.
Trump Ezra rapidement sénateur républicain
juif mystique qui m'a une paire un
message de l'
esto para para o brasil agua frappe est la
lave desta arbre est un arbre en toute sécurité sur le
fond sont privés maîtrisent le leadership L'
Amérique semble kimochi
merci à vous Madame vous parlez asticot
masculin
Vasquez  Le voyage à Vegas sur ánotá exerce un nom
de fer le livre que vous préférez exposer
si rapide allemand les étangs plusieurs menus
et tout placage sur la Bosnie Kosovo Belize
merci Madame